une journée désormais historique à cuba
raul castro 89 ans et derniers frères
castro à la tête du pays laisse place à
une nouvelle génération après six
décennies de règne castris président de
la république
miguel diaz cannelle 60 ans a pris la
succession ce lundi comme premier
secrétaire du parti communiste et
devient ainsi le premier civil dirigé
également le parti dans lequel il aura
fait toute sa carrière
un passage de témoin historique et
décisif dans une période de crise pour
cuba en pleine pandémie est sous la
pression des sanctions américaines
renforcées durant le mandat de donald
trump lors du 8ème congrès du parti
raul castro a d'ailleurs fait le voeu de
voir se développer de nouvelles
relations avec les états unis après des
décennies de conflit sous l'ère castries
ce jeu ratifie depuis ce congrès du
parti
la volonté de développer un dialogue
respectueux et de construire un nouveau
type de relations avec les etats-unis
son intention que cuba renonce aux
principes de la révolution et du
socialisme pour y parvenir
[Musique]
tant que je vivrai je serai prêt le pied
à l'étrier à défendre la patrie la
révolution et le socialisme avec plus de
force que jamais
crions vivait combat libre la fin d'une
époque pour plus de 11 millions de
cubains beaucoup d'entre eux n'auront
jamais connu d'autres dirigeants que les
frères castro
dialogue là je crois que la position de
raul castro de donner un chemin pour la
continuité dans la direction du parti a
été très importante
après avoir développé un travail louable
à la tête du parti communiste de cuba
je pense que le fait que d'autres
générations se joignent à la direction
du parti est une bonne chose
il y avait là encore ça pour cet
événement et c'est très positif de
donner de l'espace pour notre génération
des diriger le parti
cependant la nationale et l'impact et je
pense que la décision de prendre sa
retraite est la bonne devant céder la
place aux jeunes
il a plusieurs ministres miguel diaz
cannelle au sein de l'état ils ont la
capacité de diriger le pays
de toute évidence c'est un personnage
public en personnage important de la
révolution de l'histoire de notre pays
parce que depuis des années il a été un
personnage important à l'heure actuelle
depuis que fidel castro a quitté la
présidence il a bien assumé ce rôle
babel miguel jazz cannelle fidèles
partisans du castrisme ne devrait pas
révolutionner la ligne politique cubaine
actuelle face aux pénuries de produits
de première nécessité dieu à la pandémie
de kobe 19 une vague de contestation
monte dans le pays
porté par une nouvelle génération de
cubains qui s'empare des réseaux sociaux
accessibles depuis peu sur l'île miguel
gascan elle aura sans doute affaire à
une jeunesse plus revendicatrices que
celle de l'air castriste